[Music]
there is no question that justice breyer
for whom i have great respect
should retire at the end of this term
i mean my goodness have we not learned
our lesson just to be clear you do think
that justice steven breyer should retire
at the end of this term i'm inclined to
say yes i do believe that he should
retire prior to the midterms i think
that would be best for our country
progressive democrats got what they
wanted supreme court justice stephen
breyer announced his resignation
ironically this comes the same week
nancy pelosi announced she would run
again she's been in the house for 35
years
which is seven years longer than justice
breyer has been on the supreme court
progressives were in a hurry to get rid
of justice breyer who was 83 but the top
three democrats in the house
are all over the age of 80 themselves
and they don't seem to be going anywhere
irony aside briar's retirement does give
president biden a chance to fulfill at
least one campaign promise as the
midterms near joining us now is senator
marshall blackburn from the great state
of tennessee who sits on the senate
judiciary
committee welcome to you senator another
supreme court confirmation hearing i i
hope
some of your colleagues on the committee
treat this nominee with more respect
than they treated
amy coney barrett what do you think
what we know is that this is going to be
one of those fights that we will have
as to how the senate goes about
providing advice and consent which is
our responsibility and our
constitutional duty and i agree with you
it would be nice if we would see this
approached as a respectful process
respectful to the institution of the
senate and respectful to the
constitution of the united states and
make certain that we do the vetting that
is necessary
that we spend the time reviewing rulings
and writings and opinions and listening
to speeches our duty is to make certain
that we have constitutionalists
that go to the bench people that are
going to be fair that are going to
uphold that constitution and the rule of
law and trade to be certain that we do
not put people
on the supreme court or the federal
bench who are going to be activist
judges and are going to make rulings the
way they would like to see things be
rather than making rulings based on the
rule of law
you know senator
even senators that serve a long long
time and we've had quite a few in south
carolina the likelihood is that a
supreme court justice will serve longer
than any senator
so as you go through the advice and
consent process what are you looking for
in a nominee and how does that process
work
in your own mind as you're vetting these
nominees
yes and as we get a nominee then what we
will do is look at that record of their
rulings and their opinions their
writings and pull that around as and ask
those questions is this based on the
constitution is it based on the rule of
law has this person served as a judge
you know trey one of the issues we've
had with the biden administration when
it comes to putting judges on the
federal bench for district courts or
appellate courts is they are sending us
people who are to the left they're
radical
they have radical writings or opinions
they're outside of the mainstream some
of them have been very active on social
media
and have been
anti-conservatives and i have not had
that even-handed temperament
that you know so well
is expected of judges to think things
through many times we have people
presented to us who have never spent one
minute
serving as a judge in any capacity at
the city the county the state level but
they're trying to put them on the
federal bench but the vetting process is
really such an integral part of
selecting a judge who as you said this
is a lifetime appointment and i really
do feel a little bit for justice breyer
because it appears that he was being
pushed out the white house for political
gain
revealed that he was looking to retire
they did not wait for him to make this
announcement they made that announcement
on their time and in their manner to go
ahead and push him out so that they
could have a better
day in the news cycle which has not been
good for them this year yeah you know
senator i i'm so old now i've got a lot
of friends who are judges and the best
ones have this one characteristic and
comment and that is humility to know
they're not legislators they're not
super legislators it takes humility to
be a judge so
i love confirmation hearings i can't
wait to watch
you and i think there may even be a guy
from south carolina on your committee i
may watch him
too but
i look forward to it thank you for your
service hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else